SQUEEZIE-FREESTYLE DE POTES (ft SEB & Maxenss)
FREESTYLE DE POTES
(couplet 1)J'suis passé des idéaux au vidéos
de nombreuses idées floues
à la vie de fou
tu détestes mon délire mais ça t'aide pas
chaque soir ta meuf regarde et s'tape des barres
Mais nan, mais nan
Faut faire de grandes études
C'est chiant, c'est chiant
Pas b'soin regarde mes thunes
Hey
Y a plus d'enfant devant mes vidéos que devant Canal J
J'articule mal donc pour les paroles tu demandes a Nagui
Si t'es une marque j'pousse les gens a t'mettre au fond du caddie
Influenceur, j'osculte en sueur
les derniers buzz à copier car j'ai plus d'inspi
J'suis un exemple pour la jeunesse
j'sais pas changer une ampoule
Irresponsable beaucoup de stress
chaque projet m'enfonce dans l'doute
tu forces sur les réseaux
mais mon chien
pèse plus que toi
tu fumes vu les mégots
le cancer
t'es à deux doigts
Tu connais pas mes vidéos
mais t'en as maté hier
pour séduire une fille
j'fais une dédicace
pour son p'tit frère
(refrain)On a des idées
on sait pas quoi en faire
On s'est décidé
à dire des paroles en l'air
Ta tête oscille
aussitôt qu'on s'y met
Pas de consignes x2
On a des idées
on sait pas quoi en faire
On s'est décidés
à dire des paroles en l'air
Ta tête oscille
aussitôt qu'on s'y met
Pas de consignes x2
(couplet 2)J'veux la vue sur la vallée, la villa sur la mer
Vu qu'on est fêlés la finale c'est la même
On veut l'oseille de Selena
On juge sans faire l'ENA
J'suis fan comme Senna ces nazes
s'font des scènes et des scénars
Qu'est-ce qu'on essaye là
on fait du rap ou on s'éloigne
T'as le flow d'un forain
qu'aurait fini la fête
comme un connard serein
j'trouve ça facile en fait
J'suis pas si lent frère
j'suis lancinant certes
ouais j'suis quasiment cer-
tain
d'plaire à ceux qui captent
qu'on fait ce qui nous plait
parce qu'on sait kicker, simple
J'ai tendance à t'niquer
sans même m'appliquer
j'vais pas paniquer n'imp
Non j'déconne j'ai pas confiance
j'prends consciense que j'en sais rien
J'vais m'renseigner sur ça
mais j'crois seulement
qu'on s'en sort bien
On censure rien
j'ressens soudain
qu'on s'assume hein
Si tu m'insultes
j'suis pas d'celui
qui s'en souvient
j'me prête au jeu du commun des mortels
aucun démenti demande au ciel
mon potentiel j'suis démentiel
ouais devant Seb
j'vois peu d'anciens
pas de recettes
que du recel
de mes ancêtres
j'suis référencé comme préféré
t'sais, j'peux être sévère c'est vrai
c'est S.E.B
J'ose espérer
faire un CD
pour exceller
(refrain)On a des idées
on sait pas quoi en faire
On s'est décidé
à dire des paroles en l'air
Ta tête oscille
aussitôt qu'on s'y met
Pas de consignes x2
On a des idées
on sait pas quoi en faire
On s'est décidés
à dire des paroles en l'air
Ta tête oscille
aussitôt qu'on s'y met
(couplet 3)La passion nous a bercé
mais la bêtise m'a percé
J'ai pas les plus beaux pulls
les plus belles punchlines
J'ai pas les plus belles rimes
la preuve j'ai pas de time
J'ai pas les beaux airs
des grands bosseurs
j'veux mettre de ma douceur
d'ailleurs, dans tous les coeurs
(Maxou chante incompréhensiblement)
Tout c'qui sort de ta bouche
on comprend rien c'est fou
T'es plus drôle quand tu chantes
qu'à la télé Maxou
T'es marrant, talentueux
mais t'es bizarre, t'es chelou
Pourquoi tu fais pas d'vidéos ?
Pourquoi tu dis que des gros mots ?
Mais on sait pas c'que tu fais
de ta vie, de tes journées
On sait qu'c'est pour déconner
toutes tes musiques, ta tournée
J'm'étais juré d'plus chanter
de m'faire discret
d'être qu'un détail
Mais ça ne fait que commencer
c'est spécial
Quand le dimanche sera passé
ça fera mal, ce sera brutal
J'm'étais juré d'plus crier
mais ça m'obsède
c'est démonial
Quand j'sortirai du grand bain
que j'serai repu de faire du suave
J'ferai ce que j'fais d'aussi bien
quand t'es connu pour faire le zouave
Et puis qu'importe les humeurs
toujours la nostalgie qui parle
Quand le dimanche sera passé
ça fera mal, ce sera brutal
Youtubeur en demeure à ses heures perdues
Dans un train presque à l'heure entre Nîmes et Paris
j'préfère conter des douceurs
la tournée continue
J'exagère ma vie
bien que j'erre pardi
Vous avoir dans mon coeur me mènera au paradis
Heu Max t'as vraiment niqué l'ambiance là par contre
Ah ouais tu trouves ?
T'as tous niqué
(refrain)On a des idées
on sait pas en faire
On s'est décidé
à dire des paroles en l'air
Ta tête oscille
aussitôt qu'on s'y met
Pas de consignes x2
On a des idées
on sait pas quoi en faire
On s'est décidé
à dire des paroles en l'air
Ta tête oscille
aussitôt qu'on s'y met
Pas de consignes x2
La passion nous a bercé
mais la bêtise m'a percée
La passion nous a bercée
un grand merci à Max et Seb